all right China China Oh where'd you
grow up where you from originally
Oakland Oakland mm-hmm
and tell me about your family had both
your parents when you grew up my mom
died I died when I was like seven she
died because she my dad was beating on
her stuff beating her and he ended up
killing her so now he's in jail for life
so really I had to go my own and do
everything on my own
starting at 13 16 now it was three years
you started working the streets at 13
who raised you who raised me my uncle
you're all so I was out here starting
from 13 to now raised in the Nickerson
gardens yeah
projects so you're 16 now
yeah and so you're working Figueroa
Street yeah I don't work it as much but
I work almost like every night every day
it's just like I'm I want to get out of
this like so that if a lot that comes
with you working on fig you're risking
your life every day so it's like no I'm
gonna make something out of myself all
data I'm sorry I'm gonna make something
out of myself one day though that's good
you're in school still um no I graduated
because I did home school so I graduated
already so you're 16 but you graduated
high school right mm-hmm
you're good student yep I wanted to
graduate early because I know what I do
and I can't do that at the same time and
I'm not gonna be a failed in life
because I want to work on thick you know
so I had to do both at the same time and
that's what I did and yeah it got me
some weirdo so your childhood sounds
very rough because you lost you
parents yeah how was it after you your
dad went to prison and it was hard cuz
even though my mom and dad used to fight
a lot
I was so close with my dad and I was so
close with my mom if my mama didn't
having my daddy did if my dad didn't
have my mama did so it was like it hurt
me to see both of them leave me it was
like what am I gonna do now and I got
little sisters that I have to raise I
got brothers that I got a raise I got a
kid you have a child yeah he's one her
name is Anne Johnson and yeah but he's
out in Oakland so he's gonna collide
with with him he's out there with my
grandma your grandmother yeah so you
working to figure idea you work for the
pimp yeah I do
I've known one girlfriend since I
started it's been really it's been
pretty good you don't get relationship
yeah you don't hate you you don't and
I'm a quiet person when it comes to him
yelling at me I don't talk you know do
all that reckless stuff it'll be loud I
just sit they be quiet you know cuz I
just be thinking through my thoughts
like I got so much other [ __ ] that I
could be worried about dad all face so
he keeps how much your money but I get
anything I want anytime I want and
that's what I like about it that I can't
anything I want anytime I want if I want
it I'm gonna get it right there
damn in there so you could get out if
you wanted to yeah I can leave before I
wanted to you you choose to stay with
him cuz he's - he's treating you well
mm-hmm
you've been arrested out there in the
street yep I have tickets and all but
they don't really bother me number no
more as much unless it's you know nice
day or Tuesday or Thursdays they don't
really bother me because I'm not known
like I'll be out there every single day
and I don't be Nikki as much like that
either I have class from ourselves
- so yeah but I have been arrested I've
been arrested for not only prostitution
I've been arrested for stabbing girls
but it was only for my safety
I was helping myself you know defending
myself I didn't mean I was held at
gunpoint just what three weeks ago by a
pimp
and I thought he was a trick it was like
he was like me and my um my wife he me
my wife he was on 81st Street and he was
playing either Mexican but she wasn't he
was a pimp
under the mat under the helmet cos he
was on a motorcycle so after that I've
never got on a motorcycle again I got on
a motorcycle and we were just supposed
to be going to the sunrise motel which
is my motel that I was staying at the
time and we went past it he went on the
freeway he was driving off fast I didn't
know what to do I was panicking it
seemed so Ali put me out gunpoint and
the only way I could really you know not
get killed is I had to do something so
you better other bad experiences with
with your the John's you pick up you say
what do you have you had bad experiences
with the guys that pick you up no not
really Mexicans um sometimes they do
play you they they say they got this but
they really don't that's why I gave my
money beforehand now then I used to like
pay I used to charge them by time but
now it's like all together so
you recall the first time you were 13
when you started yeah what do you call
the first time you did this the first
time I did this I was scared I was on 66
and big and you told me I didn't know
what a pimp was I didn't know what a
hole was I just knew what fake was so I
had a friend telling me about it so we
go big and a whole time this pimp I'm
thinking like he's trying to be my
boyfriend or something but it's not even
that he's hopping out the car on me and
stuff I don't know I don't know what's
going on so I'm like why is he getting
out the car on me I'm thinking you got
snatched me up and stuff but they can't
touch you and if they do then something
gonna happen unless they get away but I
didn't know well what was going on and
the guy he another pimp drove past and
he was like well you had a pocket what
he expected me to do and I was like
what's out of pocket you know cuz I
didn't know what guy was then my HP she
told me she was like out of pocket you
saying you know but I didn't had no pimp
at the time but a pocket is when you
beaten into a pimp and his isn't good
stuff reading into everything he's
saying paints it you send me giving a
little bit of attention
that's out then I keep turning the
corner they gonna keep doing everything
and they're not gonna stop until you
either leave or if you don't leave
obviously you like the attention you
know so I heard this day in pocket hey
you know what's what's the worst thing
about doing us the worst thing about
doing this is I feel like if this slow
or the police that's the worst thing
about doing this is the police to me
even though like they say oh the police
can't do nothin to you on these days
that days yeah that's not true they can
do stuff to you on and once some of the
police is cool like yesterday I had
police pull up on me he was like what's
up I was like hey he was like um um
you're working on figs and I was like
yep and he was like go to Manchester
because but um yeah so I'm gonna police
do be cool instead I'd be on Long Beach
Boulevard - oh not just me
I'd be on Long Beach Boulevard and
morally at nights because um at night
because I don't want me risking more of
my life Oh big that's more of a race to
me Figaro is the busiest of the streets
but there's Western there's Long Beach
there's other areas Boulevard our drugs
are pretty early ya ask me marijuana
that's it yeah see you get depressed
sometimes doing this yeah a lot of times
because the fact that I have a little
sister and she's doing it too it's like
dang I could have taught her way much
more and just you know because I was in
group homes and stuff - I run away from
real homes just to you know work but as
soon as I got a de dar group home stuff
it was like God was like he was
punishing me in many different ways and
it was just crazy cuz it was like my
sister don't think I love her because of
the stuff that I did she don't think I
love her me going out on figure every
night she don't think I love her I was
spending time with her as much as I used
to
nothing was the same so then she started
doing it and now she think it eyes oh
I'm with my sister now no only Warner
doing this and I started out all the
time but I know I didn't listen can't
get somebody that don't listen to listen
too thick you know it's not work so I
tried my best you know to give her money
instead of her working for it as best as
I can how was your sister she's 14
working do you think you're addicted to
the fast money yeah the lifestyle of
this is so tempting right this is real
tempting because it's fast it comes up
fast and if it's slow it'll pick up
that's why you keep regulars regulars I
gotta do is call them I'm getting me
I'll fig money why you never know how
much you can get did you ever you ever
look back at your situation and just
think man this is crazy that I'm doing
this yeah cuz it's dangerous before I
was doing all this I was still wanting
to depression I was gonna do suicide
mental thoughts I was cutting all that
all over in arms everywhere just blood
and it was like crazy because I was
really gone just with stuff so me
thinking about it now it's like I feel
like I changed cuz I ain't cut in what
some years government yeah that's out
the way cuz I was doing it constantly it
was like I could have stopped cuz that's
the only thing I was taking my pain away
it's not like I smoked at the time I
wasn't allowed to
do you have dreams or goals that you
like - yeah I want to do makeup and I
want to do nails and that's a lot that's
what I'm gonna do I'm about to have my
own shop pretty soon here a nail salon
and it's gonna be a black-owned business
but I'm pretty sure it's gonna be poppin
that's gonna be a lot of money so yeah
that'd be great
that is me I was got away for all this
stuff - okay it's a hard time right now
do you think doing this for the last
three years has changed your personality
change the way you are yeah it has it
actually made me a stronger person
because of I was weak at the time you
know you I mean not same week I was in
week it was I was not in the right state
of mind I mean if you got somebody that
could put you in the right state of mind
and you ain't gotta worry as much so I
think I yeah I did change a lot like I
got more into myself more seeing who
myself was more loving myself even
though I'm on fade I still got time to
love myself and I got somebody telling
me all good thoughts all good knowledge
- so I could still overthink what I did
in the past thing now and it's like okay
I see you try me good advice would you
give to a young girl who's considering
doing something like what your dental my
advice for you is if you don't do it I'm
not gonna say cuz anybody first time
they not gonna know what they doing but
if you're gonna do it make sure you do
it right and make sure you're not doing
it all your life cuz it's been doing it
all your life what are you getting you
just give me your money to the same
person
you're not investing in it so my advice
for you is if you don't do it invest in
something don't just keep doing it all
your life
cuz that's out out how much do you think
your self-worth I mean they're just what
you believe you deserve in life plays a
part in in your decision to do this and
and getting you're getting yourself here
and because if you if you believe you're
destined for something better you
probably wouldn't allow this to happen
right yeah I wouldn't so you say right I
just wonder I wonder if like you know
you had a rough childhood because you
lost your parents and sometimes if
you're not supported the right way you
end up feeling like you don't deserve
better things in life yeah and it sounds
you have a good head on your shoulders
because you're looking to get out you're
looking to do something productive and
that's great you finish school school
early which is really remarkable so
there's a lot of a lot of positives I
see yeah but I just wonder if there's
something that brought you down this
path what brung me down this path is the
group of friends I was hanging around
saw your friends yeah but I didn't know
about nothing about hoenn had been big
none of that - I started hanging around
with good girlfriends and I thank them
group of friends sometime cuz it got me
somewhere some of them friends is still
here
I don't got what two friends are still
here other ones they ran off you know do
you a lot of friends that do this as
well yeah I mean not really friends I
got home gross
I don't do friends yeah it's family do
you have any friends I got friends
either
but they don't do big and stuff I got
one friend I do fig and she barely be
over there but how much money do you
make in a night in a night I stay like
if you working on feet but in the night
you have what's said behind your 800 if
you're doing it right or 500 if you're
doing it right but the most I've made
and one night is 4 X is what it's for
Rex you've made 4,000 a night
yes one night you gotta have a good
mouthpiece otherwise cheeks not gonna
date you yeah so when the guys pick you
up you go to the hotels you go to the
car you can do car dates you can do
hotels I yeah what really I might move
it in more to the car instead of going
to hotels faster it's faster than if
they want to go to a hotel charge them
more they do it too it's how many guys
will you do this within a night I say
like 5 4 F room if you keep like oh not
even not 5 maybe 10 maybe you know
somewhere near a lot but not a lot not a
lot cuz you can get money on it one
person over and over and over and over
again you got to go to the next person
and wait for tricking guys who are you
getting them to give you money yeah but
that's part of the game right yeah it's
part of the game they can't do don't see
if you walk out the door well tricks
right tricks you're a trick i trick do
you know so yeah does this have this
change the way you view men you think
yes it has a lot because you would never
think like a pimp is really a pimp like
you might hear it in songs I used to
hear their songs I know what it is but
be saying it and now I knowing this like
Danielle singing all that look where I
ended up yeah so the pimps today they're
not driving the big Cadillacs and the in
the flashy clothes they're they're more
undercover they're modern ones right and
do they almost look like their
boyfriends when they're coming at you
and then all of a sudden that you
realize that you're giving them their
money oh no because when you know that
I'm been doing this for so long I know
when a pimp is a pimp I know when you
just saying you a drug dealer some of
the pimps try to play oh I'm just a drug
dealer
soon as I see a black person I don't
care what it is I walk away unless you
old black man on a chip but if you not
go away you stay away from black guys
for that reason yeah they're always
playing games
mm-hmm all right China well thank you so
much for talking with me you're welcome
and good luck with your new dreams that
that'd be great to get out and do
something like that yeah you seem like
you get the ability to do that yeah it'd
be cool to see all right
you